Vines branches and tendrils grab at
682's wriggling body as the skinless
grinning face of the skeleton Queen
she is in total control for one of the
first times ever 682 has encountered a
threat who might be too powerful for
even its strength and adaptability to
surpass how could such an impossible
circumstance come to pass lost in an
endless abyss of liminal realities
separated from its closest Companions
and officially declared to be
neutralized by the SCP Foundation The
Immortal reptilian entity known as 682
continues its incomprehensible journey
through the back rooms 682 had explored
over 20 different levels of the back
rooms from vast oceans to Lost Cities to
even mind warping spaces that evoked
distant childhood memories very little
if any of what 682 had encountered could
be described as fun or adventurous in
682's mind the back rooms was a
nightmare controlled by malicious forces
that only wanted to bring harm to the
creature the lizard had faced scores of
violent entities ranging from low-level
fodder like clumps smilers and death
moths spear-wielding minibosses like
tiny and Argus and one particularly
crafty and well-equipped Explorer
through all of these encounters and the
dimension hopping hijinks that came with
them 682 had become enduring and
resilient the uncontrollable rage and
disgust for life that had defined 682's
personality during its time in
containment had gradually subsided into
an almost enlightened state of
determination
the will to be its own Master decide its
own destiny and to travel the back rooms
not as a conqueror but as an entity
seeking freedom for its sake it spent a
long time contemplating its purpose in
the cryptic ruins of the Petrified
Garden on level 23 before making a new
effort to travel between layers of the
back rooms as one might expect the next
level that 682 was able to access was
level 24 known by some as the study but
better known by its locals as the moon
even as far as levels in the back rooms
go level 24 was an unusual concept for
682 to understand at first the walkable
portion of the level appeared to be a
plastic model of a moon blown up to
colossal proportions the moon was a part
of a scale model of the solar system and
was situated inside a Victorian era
study of impossible size the exact
details of the massive room were hard to
see given the anomalous blurry filter
that appeared to impede the vision of
those who tried to look away from the
Moon
no consistent theme with the previous
levels vague and inexplicable properties
and a seemingly random resemblance to
human-made structures
classic backrooms 682 mused in the
distance expanse of the study entity 682
thought that it saw a Titanic human man
in a tuxedo pulling a book from one of
the shelves and sitting down to read it
this blurry giant was known simply as
Buford and it was the only unique entity
to this level of the back rooms the
craters and riffs of the moon were home
to swarms of death moths and clumps
though there were noticeably not as many
of these hostile entities as on previous
levels 682 regarded the presence of
these familiar foes as something of a
novelty given the amount of time it had
spent on the relatively safe level 23.
the more things change the more they
stay just as disgusting well six City 2
was not exactly pleased with having to
share the same reality as these infernal
things it was not about to rush in and
start taking names if the researchers at
the foundation could see 682 now they
might assume that the reptile had been
reformed of its violent ways this was
not the case 682 had come to accept that
these creatures had no real ecosystem or
drive to propagate themselves as other
life did the mechanics of their
existence seemed to be limited to the
mere fact that they were extensions of
the back rooms itself obstacles placed
in the path of explorers to thwart their
progress they were more like the enemies
of a video game than sentient life forms
and 682 had come to believe that
fighting them would be doing exactly
what the back rooms wanted it to do if
682 needed to defend itself it would
absolutely fight back against these
stock entities but by now it was obvious
that they were not a real
there were better games to play in the
arcade of life and 682 was not feeling
particularly flush with tokens
appropriately enough the next level that
682 arrived at level 25 was filled with
a wide selection of arcade machines once
again the back rooms had thrown another
devious curveball in the direction of
682 the hard to destroy reptile was
reminded once again of just how
unpredictable the variations in theme
could be between levels true to its
retro aesthetic level 25 seemed to be
covered in a thin layer of dust the
arcade machines themselves were damaged
and broken down the few that did seem
functional were not equipped with any
game that 682 was familiar with then
again 682 was not exactly an avid gamer
perhaps the sorry state of the arcade
would be explained by the level being
where the 80s went to die or more likely
by the fact no human Explorer had made
it this far into the back room comes in
quite some time the lack of humans in an
environment designed for them was hardly
a new occurrence inside of the back
rooms and as usual the general ideas
seem to be that something that was
usually normal like a hotel or an office
was presented in a way that made it
inconvenient an arcade where no games
could be played was certainly a bummer
but considering that it's several layers
farther down than a level where
explorers were forced to confront their
traumatic pasts and another level that
threatened all Explorers with
ever-shifting extreme environments the
plight of being stuck in a defunct
arcade was a bit of an underwhelming
concept 682 had long since accepted that
there was no linear difficulty curve to
the back rooms and given that this place
was also devoid of entities level 25
didn't seem to have much to offer the
reptile with no other options 682
decided to try one of the arcade
machines naturally it didn't carry any
quarters on its being but that was only
a minor quibble to a creature as
adaptable as 682 I can do anything as
682 approached one of the functional
arcade machines it developed a
quarter-shaped skin tag on the tip of
its snout similar to the knobby growth
of a male Geral crocodile it extended
this growth towards the coin slot on a
wire thin appendage as if it were an
actual quarter 682 did its best
impression of placing a quarter inside
of an arcade machine once the machine
blinked to life 682 retracted its
organic quarter the bright screen of the
cabinet began to shuffle rapidly through
numbers like a slot machine it did this
for several minutes until landing on the
number 28 Sparks of energy course
through the arcade cabinet and a sudden
burst of light Wist 682 several levels
ahead 682 could see a tunnel of light on
all sides as it flew through the liminal
space between liminal spaces it was able
to perceive a hint of level 2 6 a
seemingly ordinary apartment building
and level 27 an innocent looking hot
spring inside of a cave both Concepts
were old hat at this point so 682 didn't
feel too bad about skipping them besides
it was a free being now and what was
Freer than breaking the rules and
skipping a few levels unless the back
rooms was hoping it would do that but
there was no time to think about the
inscruciable intentions of the Abyss
creators because 682 had reached the
other side of the light tunnel and had
been deposited into level 28 a dimension
with a navy blue sky and a single large
Castle on a hill the only Landmark 682
moved towards the castle and was greeted
by the sound of great Thunder above dark
storm clouds began to fill the sky as
rain poured down onto the forested
valley surrounding the keep while now
ordinary storm would deter being as
powerful as 682 the howling winds and
flashes of Lights signaled that this
weather was anything But Ordinary the
reptile naturally decided to continue
into the only available shelter the
castle it barged in through one of the
walls in an effort to hide itself from
the elements it soon learned that it was
not alone a foreboding figure approached
from the darkness of the keep clad head
to toe in colorful blue armor who goes
there answer me you scalene
feeling a bit spicy 682 decided to break
out an old favorite threat what good
does it do for a lamb to know the name
of its butcher I am simply passing
through you're just one more lifeless
husk dreamed up by the back rooms so
leave me be and return to your dull
routine of scaring weak humans foul
Beast the blue Knight said I would never
scare humans on purpose I happen to
quite respect them as a matter of fact I
have met a particularly good human who
taught me so many wonderful things
say you've met a good human 682 asked
other than the exception of the Dead I
cannot think of any humans that are
worthy of existence let alone good well
then you don't know Sarah the blue
Knight said seemingly in a state of
rising emotional distress the storm
outside began to grow in intensity in
response to the Blue Knights provoked
reaction 682 found this somewhat
intriguing and decided to push the
armored figure a bit further is she your
girlfriend
682 taunted 682 was becoming
simultaneously more amused and disgusted
by this blue Knight as the interaction
went on it was clear that the blue
Knight was a bit of a lunatic and
definitely a soft-hearted being though
as 682 pondered his words an odd feeling
of realization washed over the reptile
was the current situation regarding
682's lost traveling companion entity 7
Jerry not dissimilar from what the night
was going through in regards to this
human named Sarah 682 had learned much
about the back rooms during his time
traveling with the blue Hyacinth Macaw
and did miss the avian entity very much
the idea that Jerry may have forgotten
about 682 and might be on adventures
somewhere else made 682 almost feel
regretful suddenly tormenting this
overly sensitive Knight didn't seem to
be that much fun to 682 all at once the
reptile wanted out of this level so he
ordered the Knight to give him an exit
the blue Knight shook his head for a bit
but ultimately relented he led 682 to an
archway deep in the castle made of solid
bones it was a dimensional portal like
many of those seen in the back rooms and
it was carved with a number 32. these
portal shall take you to the forest of
the skeleton Queen on level 32. it is a
dangerous place where you will almost
certainly meet your demise the skeleton
Queen is not known for her Hospitality
the force of the skeleton Queen was
about what one might expect from its
name a dark and gloomy Woodland beneath
a starless sky and a crescent moon of
course there was also the countless
skeletons floating amongst the trees to
give the level some personality all of
them seemed somewhat alive but like many
of the back room's other tricks this may
have only been an illusion it will do
before 682 could even fully take in the
scenery he could see another entity
moving between the trees it seemed to be
a human woman in a Victorian dress and
skeletal face paint she appeared to
Jester to 682 beckoning the reptile into
the forest there was nothing to lose yet
so 682 took to the mysterious woman's
provocation and followed her not too far
down the path 682 lost sight of this
strange human woman it was as if she had
been there a moment and was gone the
next 682 pondered the the odd nature of
this encounter and decided to turn back
around and follow a different path as
soon as the reptile turned the woman
appeared before it again but this time
her overall form was more Sinister she
was tall and gaunt with hardly any skin
in the white of her bones shown
ominously in the Moonlight she smiled an
evil smile and without a single word she
snapped her fingers causing the entire
Forest to immediately turn on 682 it was
an attack more sudden and more complete
than any 682 had ever experienced there
was no chance to censor hostility no
room to adapt or to react the trees took
hold of six City too and in a display of
immense Supernatural power that defiled
logic tour 682's very Spirit out of its
physical form and dragged it into the
darkness beneath the forest in its long
and miserable life The Immortal reptile
682 had endured every punish and form of
damage in creation But Here and Now in
the back rooms for the very first time
682 would not have the luxury of its
hard to destroy infinitely adaptable
body it was now a helpless disembodied
Soul without any means to defend itself
the perfect play thing for the skeleton
Queen herself now go check out could
scp-682 be contained in the back rooms
and scp-682 makes friends in backrooms
for more